binz qui vous nous avez rejoint bonsoir
et
voilà la d1000 routine qui utilisent
toujours les mêmes termes
il dit combattre les néo nazis en
ukraine et puis il a beaucoup glorifier
aussi les héros russe tombé sur le champ
de bataille alors comme le disait l'ena
précédemment c'est intéressant parce que
effectivement il ya toujours un paquet
de mesures dites sociales alors là on
peut rire quand même vladimir poutine le
social aujourd'hui le social qui dit
qu'il est fier de ses forces armées ou
est-ce qu'il est fier de la chair à
canon qui l'envoie en ukraine ce que la
question est là alors on a bien dit et
ont cessé c'était normal c'était notre
devoir de dire qu'il ne pouvait pas y
avoir cinq mille soldats russes tués par
les ukrainiens en moins d'une semaine
mais enfin il y en a beaucoup et vous
disiez 490 donc allé cinq sens
à ce qui est intéressant c'est que de ce
fait là il accepte il reconnaît ce que
disait l'ena doute à leur fait que
l'opération spéciale pour entre
guillemets comme il l'appelle et
meurtrière une opération spéciale quand
on dit qu'on fait une opération de
maintien de la paix comme ça a été le
cas d'une opération d'abord qu'on ne
mène pas avec des tanks et de l'aviation
et du bombardement mais qui ne fait pas
autant de morts est donc là nous sommes
en train de retourner
j'allais dire halak à la tragédie
habituel des russes et même des slaves
c'est à dire qu on ne conçoit l'action
et l'énergique partir de la souffrance
je vais pas faire de psychologie des
peuples mais enfin il ya par exemple
dans l'histoire qui prouve cela et c'est
comme ça aussi alors aussi vladimir
poutine veut faire de l'histoire c'est
comme ça aussi qu'en 1941 les russes ont
été galvanisés pour aller combattre les
nazis alors que deux ans plus tôt on
leur avait dit que non il était associé
puisqu'il y avait le pacte
germano-soviétique
donc prêt primo c'est ça c'est
l'acceptation la reconnaissance qu'il ya
quelque chose qui ne va pas bien et du
coup on l'intègre comme une souffrance
de laquelle on doit ressortir encore
meilleure encore plus fort
deuxièmement le plan se déroule comme
prévu maintenant s'ils se dérouler comme
prévu on n'aurait pas assisté à des
problèmes de logistique comme ceux qui
connaissent déjà
charles dirige vers kiev c'est
doublement intéressant parce que selon
toutes nos informations cette colonne de
chars a été empêchée dans sa progression
non seulement par des problèmes
d'approvisionnement en carburant mais
aussi parce qu'un certain nombre
d'ordres se contredisent et que quand
vous mettez une action de la suite de la
sorte il faut accumuler les vagues et
non pas une seule colonne d'un seul coup
et que donc les ordres concernant d un
premier rideau un deuxième rideau un
troisième rideau se sont télescopés donc
là c'est intéressant parce que ça veut
dire aussi que dans la manière de
conduire la guerre il y avait
probablement cette idée de la guerre
n'allait pas durer quel allait être
pliée en quatre cinq jours voire une
semaine qu'il n'y aurait pas à cette
résistance qu'il n'y aurait pas cette
résistants alors cette résistance venons
vient de mot résistance néonazis chez
coûter moi je veux bien qu'on parle de
ça on parle de stepan bandera qui était
stepan bandera c'était un nationalistes
ukrainiens qui effectivement au début de
la guerre la deuxième guerre mondiale a
prêté main forte aux nazis et les
polonais d'ailleurs son souviennent
puisque par stepan wendel a beaucoup
deux pôles et des deux polonais juifs de
tziganes d'homosexuels ont été exécutés
et donc vendre un service auxiliaire à
hitler à tel point qu'hier en a eu peur
et qu'il a fait exécuter mais tout ça
c'est 1941 vous voyez ça n'est pas
2020-2022 guèye 1995 non et depuis
évidemment que les choses ont changé je
vous donne un seul exemple de ce
changement je viens de vous dire que les
hommes de sepang bandeira avait exécuté
des polonais ou les polonais s'en
souviennent ils s'en sont souvenus
aujourd'hui on voit quoi on joue on voit
que les polonais même avec un
gouvernement ultraconservateur qui n'est
pas très éloigné des options de vladimir
poutine en politique que fait-il de ce
gouvernement ils accueillent des
ukrainiens ça veut bien dire que
l'histoire a été surmontée qu'on l'a
digérée qu'on la lui qu'on la lui sans
la mettre dans un glacier ou dans un
congélateur dont la ressortir et pour
qu'elle est toujours les mêmes microbes
et les mêmes bactéries c'est ça que fait
vladimir poutine il ne s'est pas
regarder l'histoire il est isolé dans sa
vision des choses au point de croire
lui-même aux fantasmes qu'ils inventent
c'est ça qui est très mais c'est propre
à chaque dictateur en fin de compte in
elena volochine qui a beaucoup parlé des
ethnies présentes en russie et il a
souligné les russes et les ukrainiens
sont un seul peuple oui alors c'est un
peu ce fameux mythe soviétique de
l'amitié entre les peuples c'est à dire
que encore une fois à vladimir poutine
souligne très souvent que ce n'est pas
une guerre contre les ukrainiens c'est
une guerre contre des nazis donc il
brandit d épouvantail brandi des grands
mots qui font peur aux russes et qui
requit réveillent dans leur dans leur
conscience collective des pages sombres
et des pages qui ont finalement été le
socle le fondement du patriotisme à
savoir la victoire soviétique avec le
chef des armées staline dans ce que la
en russie on appelle la grande guerre
patriotique c'est à dire la seconde
guerre mondiale donc il ya cette notion
d'ennemi l'ennemi ne peut pas être le
peuple ukrainien parce que c'est neutre
au pape les frères mais l'ennemi c'est
les nazis sont un ennemi de toujours
historique et c'est le grand mal
évidemment sauf que nous on s'en
dissocie et est donc de ce point de vue
là peu importe que le cren à vau-l'eau
dit merci dance qui est sa confession
comme président peu importe que c'est
complètement inventé toute cette
histoire de nazis depuis le début depuis
2014 et l'annexion de la crimée elle est
partie d'où cette histoire de nazis faut
rappeler aussi les choses c'est à dire
que 2014 vous avez la révolution pro
européenne sur maïdan et vous avez
différentes différents différentes
factions différents mouvements qui se
forme dans des mouvements très
nationaliste et celui de travis hector
préavis sector c'est le aile droite donc
c'est effectivement un mouvement qui est
très nationaliste qui est très très
[Musique]
sûr les idées nationales l'ukraine eux
aux ukrainiens etc etc comme vous avez
aussi des mouvements ultra nationalistes
en russie qui sont d'ailleurs très très
proches du pouvoir est instrumentalisée
par le pouvoir met donc ceci a été
repris amplifiée avec quelques images de
croix gammées dessinées dans des dents
dans des quartiers de kiev au moment de
la révolution de maidan comme aussi il y
en a en russie mais ceci a été amplifiée
pour dire que tout cela a été une
révolution qui a été conduite finalement
par les nazis donc la propagande
s'empare de petits éléments de
l'histoire jusqu'à ce que ensuite on
invente des checkpoints des checkpoints
détruit et ses hommes vont trouver soi
disant des cartes de visite de faire de
ce fameux pour approuver secteur à qui
on a ensuite attribuer tous les maux de
l'ukraine et donc c'était pouvant taille
des nazis arrivée au pouvoir suite à la
révolution de maidan ce que vladimir
poutine nous ressort jusqu'à son
discours et qui ressort toujours dans
tous les discours officiels russes
depuis le début de ce conflit qu'on
n'entend pas depuis l'occident qu'on
commence à entendre seulement maintenant
au vu de l'ampleur des événements mais
c'est un discours qui absolument
absolument permanent parce qu'il faut
une adhésion des russes à ceux à cette
guerre et du moins à cette opération qui
ne peut pas être celle ci on leur dit on
est en train de mener une opération
contre les ukrainiens merci beaucoup
elena volochine